The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So today, we're going to start
by taking stock of what we
discussed last time, review the
definition of Markov chains.
And then most of the lecture,
we're going to concentrate on
their steady-state behavior.
Meaning, we're going to look at
what does a Markov chain do
if it has run for a long time.
What can we say about
the probabilities of
the different states?
So what I would like to repeat
is a statement I made last
time that Markov chains
is a very, very
useful class of models.
Pretty much anything in
the real world can be
approximately modeled by a
Markov chain provided that you
set your states in
the proper way.
So we're going to see
some examples.
You're going to see more
examples in the problems
you're going to do in homework
and recitation.
On the other hand, we're
not going to go
too deep into examples.
Rather, we're going to develop
the general methodology.
OK.
All right.
Markov models can be
pretty general.
They can run in continuous
or discrete time.
They can have continuous or
discrete state spaces.
In this class, we're going to
stick just to the case where
the state space is discrete and
time is discrete because
this is the simplest case.
And also, it's the one where
you build your intuition
before going to more
general cases
perhaps in other classes.
So the state is discrete
and finite.
There's a finite number
of states.
At any point in time, the
process is sitting on one of
those states.
Time is discrete, so at each
unit of time, somebody
whistles and then
the state jumps.
And when it jumps, it can either
land in the same place,
or it can land somewhere else.
And the evolution of the
process is described by
transition probabilities.
Pij is the probability that the
next state is j given that
the current state is i.
And the most important property
that the Markov chain
has, the definition of a
Markov chain or Markov
process, is that this
probability, Pij, is the same
every time that you
land at state i --
no matter how you got there
and also no matter
what time it is.
So the model we have is time
homogeneous, which basically
means that those transition
probabilities are the same at
every time.
So the model is time invariant
in that sense.
So we're interested in what the
chain or the process is
going to do in the longer run.
So we're interested, let's say,
in the probability that
starting at a certain state, n
times steps later, we find
ourselves at some particular
state j.
Fortunately, we can calculate
those probabilities
recursively.
Of course, at the first time 1,
the probability of being 1
time later at state j given that
we are right now at state
i, by definition, this is just
the transition probabilities.
So by knowing these, we can
start a recursion that tells
us the transition probabilities
for more than n steps.
This recursion, it's
a formula.
It's always true.
You can copy it or
memorize it.
But there is a big idea behind
that formula that you should
keep in mind.
And basically, the divide
and conquer idea.
It's an application of the
total probability law.
So let's fix i.
The probability that you find
yourself at state j, you break
it up into the probabilities of
the different ways that you
can get to state j.
What are those different ways?
The different ways are the
different states k at which
you might find yourself
the previous time.
So with some probability, with
this probability, you find
yourself at state k
the previous time.
And then with probability
Pkj, you make a
transition to state j.
So this is a possible scenario
that takes you to state j
after n transitions.
And by summing over all the k's,
then we have considered
all the possible scenarios.
Now, before we move to the more
serious stuff, let's do a
little bit of warm up to get
a handle on how we use
transition probabilities to
calculate more general
probabilities, then talk about
some structural properties of
Markov chains, and then
eventually get to the main
business of today, which is
a steady-state behavior.
So somebody gives you this
chain, and our convention is
that those arcs that are not
shown here corresponds to 0
probabilities.
And each one of the arcs that's
shown has a non-zero
probability, and somebody
gives it to us.
Suppose that the chain
starts at state 1.
We want to calculate the
probability that it follows
this particular path.
That is, it goes to 2,
then to 6, then to 7.
How do we calculate the
probability of a particular
trajectory?
Well, this is the
probability--
so it's the probability of the
trajectory from 1 that you go
to 2, then to 6, then to 7.
So the probability of this
trajectory is we use the
multiplication rule.
The probability of several
things happening is the
probability that the first
thing happens, which is a
transition from 1 to 2.
And then given that we are at
state 2, we multiply with a
conditional probability that
the next event happens.
That is, that X2 is equal to 6
given that right now, we are
at state 1.
And that conditional probability
is just P26.
And notice that this conditional
probability
applies no matter how
we got to state 2.
This is the Markov assumption.
So we don't care about the
fact that we came in in a
particular way.
Given that we came in here, this
probability P26, that the
next transition takes us to 6.
And then given that all that
stuff happened, so given that
right now, we are at state 6,
we need to multiply with a
conditional probability that the
next transition takes us
to state 7.
And this is just the P67.
So to find the probability
of following a specific
trajectory, you just multiply
the transition probabilities
along the particular
trajectory.
Now, if you want to calculate
something else, such as for
example, the probability that
4 time steps later, I find
myself at state 7 given that
they started, let's say, at
this state.
How do you calculate
this probability?
One way is to use the recursion
for the Rijs that we
know that it is always valid.
But for short and simple
examples, and with a small
time horizon, perhaps you can do
this in a brute force way.
What would be the
brute force way?
This is the event that 4 time
steps later, I find
myself at state 7.
This event can happen
in various ways.
So we can take stock of all the
different ways, and write
down their probabilities.
So starting from 2.
One possibility is to follow
this trajectory, 1 transition,
2 transitions, 3 transitions,
4 transitions.
And that takes me to state 7.
What's the probability
of this trajectory?
It's P26 times P67 times
P76 and then times P67.
So this is a probability of a
particular trajectory that
takes you to state 7
after 4 time steps.
But there's other trajectories
as well.
What could be it?
I might start from state 2, go
to state 6, stay at state 6,
stay at state 6 once more.
And then from state
6, go to state 7.
And so there must be one more.
What's the other one?
I guess I could go 1, 2, 6, 7.
OK.
That's the other trajectory.
Plus P21 times P12 times
P26 and times P67.
So the transition probability,
the overall probability of
finding ourselves at state 7,
is broken down as the sum of
the probabilities of all the
different ways that I can get
to state 7 in exactly 4 steps.
So we could always do that
without knowing much about
Markov chains or the general
formula for the
Rij's that we had.
What's the trouble with
this procedure?
The trouble with this procedure
is that the number
of possible trajectories becomes
quite large if this
index is a little bigger.
If this 4 was 100, and you
ask how many different
trajectories of length 100 are
there to take me from here to
there, that number of
trajectories would be huge.
It grows exponentially with
the time horizon.
And this kind of calculation
would be impossible.
The basic equation, the
recursion that have for the
Rij's is basically a clever
way of organizing this
computation so that the amount
of computation that you do is
not exponential in
the time horizon.
Rather, it's sort of linear
with the time horizon.
For each time step you need in
the time horizon, you just
keep repeating the same
iteration over and over.
OK.
Now, the other thing that we
discussed last time, briefly,
was a classification of the
different states of the Markov
chain in two different types.
A Markov chain, in general, has
states that are recurrent,
which means that from a
recurrent state, I can go
somewhere else.
But from that somewhere else,
there's always some way of
coming back.
So if you have a chain of this
form, no matter where you go,
no matter where you start,
you can always come
back where you started.
States of this kind are
called recurrent.
On the other hand, if you have
a few states all this kind, a
transition of this type, then
these states are transient in
the sense that from those
states, it's possible to go
somewhere else from which place
there's no way to come
back where you started.
The general structure of a
Markov chain is basically a
collection of transient
states.
You're certain that you are
going to leave the transient
states eventually.
And after you leave the
transient states, you enter
into a class of states in
which you are trapped.
You are trapped if you
get inside here.
get inside there.
This is a recurrent
class of states.
From any state, you can
get to any other
state within this class.
That's another recurrent
class.
From any state inside here,
you can get anywhere else
inside that class.
But these 2 classes, you
do not communicate.
If you start here, there's
no way to get there.
If you have 2 recurrent classes,
then it's clear that
the initial conditions
of your Markov chain
matter in the long run.
If you start here, you will be
stuck inside here for the long
run and similarly about here.
So the initial conditions
do make a difference.
On the other hand, if this class
was not here and you
only had that class, what would
happen to the chain?
Let's say you start here.
You move around.
At some point, you make
that transition.
You get stuck in here.
And inside here, you keep
circulating, because of the
randomness, you keep visiting
all states over and over.
And hopefully or possibly, in
the long run, it doesn't
matter exactly what time it is
or where you started, but the
probability of being at that
particular state is the same
no matter what the initial
condition was.
So with a single recurrent
class, we hope that the
initial conditions
do not matter.
With 2 or more recurrent
classes, initial conditions
will definitely matter.
So how many recurrent classes we
have is something that has
to do with the long-term
behavior of the chain and the
extent to which initial
conditions matter.
Another way that initial
conditions may matter is if a
chain has a periodic
structure.
There are many ways of
defining periodicity.
The one that I find sort of the
most intuitive and with
the least amount
of mathematical
symbols is the following.
The state space of a chain is
said to be periodic if you can
lump the states into a number
of clusters called
d clusters or groups.
And the transition diagram has
the property that from a
cluster, you always
make a transition
into the next cluster.
So here d is equal to 2.
We have two subsets of
the state space.
Whenever we're here, next
time we'll be there.
time we will be there.
So this chain has a periodic
structure.
There may be still
some randomness.
When I jump from here to here,
the state to which I jump may
be random, but I'm sure that I'm
going to be inside here.
And then next time, I will be
sure that I'm inside here.
This would be a structure of a
diagram in which we have a
period of 3.
If you start in this lump, you
know that the next time, you
would be in a state
inside here.
Next time, you'll be in a state
inside here, and so on.
So these chains certainly have
a periodic structure.
And that periodicity
gets maintained.
If I start, let's say, at this
lump, at even times,
I'm sure I'm here.
At odd times, I'm
sure I am here.
So the exact time does matter
in determining the
probabilities of the
different states.
And in particular, the
probability of being at the
particular state cannot convert
to a state value.
The probability of being at the
state inside here is going
to be 0 for all times.
In general, it's going
to be some positive
number for even times.
So it goes 0 positive, zero,
positive, 0 positive.
Doesn't settle to anything.
So when we have periodicity,
we do not expect the states
probabilities to converge to
something, but rather, we
expect them to oscillate.
Now, how can we tell whether
a Markov chain
is periodic or not?
There are systematic ways of
doing it, but usually with the
types of examples we see in this
class, we just eyeball
the chain, and we tell whether
it's periodic or not.
So is this chain down here, is
it the periodic one or not?
How many people think
it's periodic?
No one.
One.
How many people think
it's not periodic?
OK.
Not periodic?
Let's see.
Let me do some drawing here.
OK.
Is it periodic?
It is.
From a red state, you can only
get to a white state.
And from a white state, you can
only get to a red state.
So this chain, even though it's
not apparent from the
picture, actually has
this structure.
We can group the states into red
states and white states.
And from reds, we always go to
a white, and from a white, we
always go to a red.
So this tells you
that sometimes
eyeballing is not as easy.
If you have lots and lots of
states, you might have some
trouble doing this exercise.
On the other hand, something
very useful to know.
Sometimes it's extremely
easy to tell that the
chain is not periodic.
What's that case?
Suppose that your chain has a
self-transition somewhere.
Then automatically,
you know that your
chain is not periodic.
So remember, the definition of
periodicity requires that if
you are in a certain group of
states, next time, you will be
in a different group.
But if you have
self-transitions, that
property is not true.
If you have a possible
self-transition, it's possible
that you stay inside your own
group for the next time step.
So whenever you have a
self-transition, this implies
that the chain is
not periodic.
And usually that's the simplest
and easy way that we
can tell most of the time that
the chain is not periodic.
So now, we come to the big topic
of today, the central
topic, which is the question
about what does the chain do
in the long run.
The question we are asking and
which we motivated last time
by looking at an example.
It's something that did happen
in our example of last time.
So we're asking whether
this happens for
every Markov chain.
We're asking the question
whether the probability of
being at state j at some
time n settles to a
steady-state value.
Let's call it pi sub j.
That these were asking whether
this quantity has a limit as n
goes to infinity, so that
we can talk about the
steady-state probability
of state j.
And furthermore, we asked
whether the steady-state
probability of that state
does not depend
on the initial state.
In other words, after the chain
runs for a long, long
time, it doesn't matter exactly
what time it is, and
it doesn't matter where the
chain started from.
You can tell me the probability
that the state is
a particular j is approximately
the steady-state
probability pi sub j.
It doesn't matter exactly what
time it is as long as you tell
me that a lot of time
has elapsed so
that n is a big number.
So this is the question.
We have seen examples, and we
understand that this is not
going to be the case always.
For example, as I just
discussed, if we have 2
recurrent classes, where
we start does matter.
The probability pi(j) of being
in that state j is going to be
0 if we start here, but it would
be something positive if
we were to start in that lump.
So the initial state does matter
if we have multiple
recurrent classes.
But if we have only a single
class of recurrent states from
each one of which you can get
to any other one, then we
don't have that problem.
Then we expect initial
conditions to be forgotten.
So that's one condition
that we need.
And then the other condition
that we need is that the chain
is not periodic.
If the chain is periodic, then
these Rij's do not converge.
They keep oscillating.
If we do not have periodicity,
then there is hope that we
will get the convergence
that we need.
It turns out this is the big
theory of Markov chains-- the
steady-state convergence
theorem.
It turns out that yes, the
rijs do converge to a
steady-state limit, which
we call a steady-state
probability as long as these two
conditions are satisfied.
We're not going to prove
this theorem.
If you're really interested, the
end of chapter exercises
basically walk you through a
proof of this result, but it's
probably a little too much for
doing it in this class.
What is the intuitive idea
behind this theorem?
Let's see.
Let's think intuitively
as to why the initial
state doesn't matter.
Think of two copies of the chain
that starts at different
initial states, and the
state moves randomly.
As the state moves randomly
starting from the two initial
states a random trajectory.
as long as you have a single
recurrent class at some point,
and you don't have periodicity
at some point, those states,
those two trajectories,
are going to collide.
Just because there's enough
randomness there.
Even though we started from
different places, the state is
going to be the same.
After the state becomes the
same, then the future of these
trajectories, probabilistically,
is the same
because they both started
at the same state.
So this means that the
initial conditions
stopped having any influence.
That's sort of the high-level
idea of why the initial state
gets forgotten.
Even if you started at different
initial states, at
some time, you may find yourself
to be in the same
state as the other trajectory.
And once that happens, your
initial conditions cannot have
any effect into the future.
All right.
So let's see how we might
calculate those steady-state
probabilities.
The way we calculate the
steady-state probabilities is
by taking this recursion, which
is always true for the
end-step transition
probabilities, and take the
limit of both sides.
The limit of this side is the
steady-state probability of
state j, which is pi sub j.
The limit of this
side, we put the
limit inside the summation.
Now, as n goes to infinity,
n - also goes to infinity.
So this Rik is going to be the
steady-state probability of
state k starting from state i.
Now where we started
doesn't matter.
So this is just the
steady-state
probability of state k.
So this term converges to that
one, and this gives us an
equation that's satisfied
by the steady-state
probabilities.
Actually, it's not
one equation.
We get one equation for
each one of the j's.
So if we have 10 possible
states, we're going to get the
system of 10 linear equations.
In the unknowns, pi(1)
up to pi(10).
OK.
10 unknowns, 10 equations.
You might think that
we are in business.
But actually, this system of
equations is singular.
0 is a possible solution
of this system.
If you plug pi equal to
zero everywhere, the
equations are satisfied.
It does not have a unique
solution, so maybe we need one
more condition to get the
uniquely solvable system of
linear equations.
It turns out that this
system of equations
has a unique solution.
If you impose an additional
condition, which is pretty
natural, the pi(j)'s are the
probabilities of the different
states, so they should
add to 1.
So you want this one equation
to the mix.
And once you do that, then this
system of equations is
going to have a unique
solution.
And so we can find the
steady-state probabilities of
the Markov chain by just
solving these linear
equations, which is numerically
straightforward.
Now, these equations are
quite important.
I mean, they're the central
point in the Markov chain.
They have a name.
They're called the balance
equations.
And it's worth interpreting
them in a
somewhat different way.
So intuitively, one can
sometimes think of
probabilities as frequencies.
For example, if I toss an
unbiased coin, probability 1/2
of heads, you could also say
that if I keep flipping that
coin, in the long run,
1/2 of the time, I'm
going to see heads.
Similarly, let's try an
interpretation of this pi(j),
the steady-state probability,
the long-term probability of
finding myself at state j.
Let's try to interpret it as
the frequency with which I
find myself at state j if
I run a very, very long
trajectory over that
Markov chain.
So the trajectory moves
around, visits states.
It visits the different states
with different frequencies.
And let's think of the
probability that you are at a
certain state as being sort of
the same as the frequency of
visiting that state.
This turns out to be a
correct statement.
If you were more rigorous, you
would have to prove it.
But it's an interpretation which
is valid and which gives
us a lot of intuition about what
these equation is saying.
So let's think as follows.
Let's focus on a particular
state j, and think of
transitions into the state j
versus transitions out of the
state j, or transitions into
j versus transitions
starting from j.
So transition starting
from that includes a
self-transition.
Ok.
So how often do we get a
transition, if we interpret
the pi(j)'s as frequencies,
how often do we get a
transition into j?
Here's how we think about it.
A fraction pi(1) of the time,
we're going to be at state 1.
Whenever we are at state 1,
there's going to be a
probability, P1j, that we make
a transition of this kind.
So out of the times that we're
at state 1, there's a
frequency, P1j with which the
next transition is into j.
So out of the overall number of
transitions that happen at
the trajectory, what fraction
of those transitions is
exactly of that kind?
That fraction of transitions is
the fraction of time that
you find yourself at 1 times the
fraction with which out of
one you happen to visit
next state j.
So we interpreted this number
as the frequency of
transitions of this kind.
At any given time, our chain
can do transitions of
different kinds, transitions of
the general form from some
k, I go to some l.
So we try to do some
accounting.
How often does a transition of
each particular kind happen?
And this is the frequency with
which transitions of that
particular kind happens.
Now, what's the total
frequency of
transitions into state j?
Transitions into state j can
happen by having a transition
from 1 to j, from 2 to j,
or from state m to j.
So to find the total frequency
with which we would observe
transitions into j is going
to be this particular sum.
Now, you are at state j if and
only if the last transition
was into state j.
So the frequency with which you
are at j is the frequency
with which transitions
into j happen.
So this equation expresses
exactly that statement.
The probability of being at
state j is the sum of the
probabilities that the last
transition was into state j.
Or in terms of frequencies, the
frequency with which you
find yourself at state j is the
sum of the frequencies of
all the possible transition
types that take you
inside state j.
So that's a useful intuition
to have, and we're going to
see an example a little later
that it gives us short cuts
into analyzing Markov chains.
But before we move,
let's revisit the
example from last time.
And let us write down
the balance
equations for this example.
So the steady-state probability
that I find myself
at state 1 is the probability
that the previous time I was
at state 1 and I made
a self-transition--
So the probability that I was
here last time and I made a
transition of this kind, plus
the probability that the last
time I was here and I made a
transition of that kind.
So plus pi(2) times 0.2.
And similarly, for the other
states, the steady-state
probably that I find myself at
state 2 is the probability
that last time I was at state 1
and I made a transition into
state 2, plus the probability
that the last time I was at
state 2 and I made the
transition into state 1.
Now, these are two
equations and two
unknowns, pi(1) and pi(2).
But you notice that both of
these equations tell you the
same thing.
They tell you that 0.5pi(1)
equals 0.2pi(2).
Either of these equations tell
you exactly this if you move
terms around.
So these two equations are
not really two equations.
It's just one equation.
They are linearly dependent
equations, and in order to
solve the problem, we need the
additional condition that
pi(1) + pi(2) is equal to 1.
Now, we have our system
of two equations,
which you can solve.
And once you solve it, you find
that pi(1) is 2/7 and
pi(2) is 5/7.
So these are the steady state
probabilities of the two
different states.
If we start this chain, at some
state, let's say state 1,
and we let it run for a long,
long time, the chain settles
into steady state.
What does that mean?
It does not mean that
the state itself
enters steady state.
The state will keep jumping
around forever and ever.
It will keep visiting both
states once in a while.
So the jumping never ceases.
The thing that gets into
steady state is the
probability of finding
yourself at state 1.
So the probability that you find
yourself at state 1 at
time one trillion is
approximately 2/7.
The probability you find
yourself at state 1 at time
two trillions is again,
approximately 2/7.
So the probability of being in
that state settles into a
steady value.
That's what the steady-state
convergence means.
It's convergence of
probabilities, not convergence
of the process itself.
And again, the two main things
that are happening in this
example, and more generally,
when we have a single class
and no periodicity, is
that the initial
state does not matter.
There's enough randomness here
so that no matter where you
start, the randomness kind of
washes out any memory of where
you started.
And also in this example,
clearly, we do not have
periodicity because
we have self arcs.
And this, in particular, implies
that the exact time
does not matter.
So now, we're going to spend
the rest of our time by
looking into a special class
of chains that's a little
easier to deal with,
but still, it's
an important class.
So what's the moral from here?
This was a simple example with
two states, and we could find
the steady-state probabilities
by solving a simple system of
two-by-two equations.
If you have a chain with 100
states, it's no problem for a
computer to solve a system
of 100-by-100 equations.
But you can certainly not do it
by hand, and usually, you
cannot get any closed-form
formulas, so you do not
necessarily get a
lot of insight.
So one looks for special
structures or models that
maybe give you a little more
insight or maybe lead you to
closed-form formulas.
And an interesting subclass of
Markov chains in which all of
these nice things do happen,
is the class
of birth/death processes.
So what's a birth/death
process?
It's a Markov chain who's
diagram looks
basically like this.
So the states of the Markov
chain start from 0 and go up
to some finite integer m.
What's special about this chain
is that if you are at a
certain state, next time you can
either go up by 1, you can
go down by 1, or you
can stay in place.
So it's like keeping track
of some population
at any given time.
One person gets born,
or one person
dies, or nothing happens.
Again, we're not accounting
for twins here.
So we're given this structure,
and we are given the
transition probabilities, the
probabilities associated with
transitions of the
different types.
So we use P's for the upward
transitions, Q's for the
downward transitions.
An example of a chain of this
kind was the supermarket
counter model that we
discussed last time.
That is, a customer arrives,
so this increments
the state by 1.
Or a customer finishes service,
in which case, the
state gets decremented by 1,
or nothing happens in which
you stay in place, and so on.
In the supermarket model, these
P's inside here were all
taken to be equal because we
assume that the arrival rate
was sort of constant
at each time slot.
But you can generalize a little
bit by assuming that
these transition probabilities
P1 here, P2 there, and so on
may be different from
state to state.
So in general, from state
i, there's going to be a
transition probability
Pi that the next
transition is upwards.
And there's going to be a
probability Qi that the next
transition is downwards.
And so from that state, the
probability that the next
transition is downwards is
going to be Q_(i+1).
So this is the structure
of our chain.
As I said, it's a crude model
of what happens at the
supermarket counter but it's
also a good model for lots of
types of service systems.
Again, you have a server
somewhere that has a buffer.
Jobs come into the buffer.
So the buffer builds up.
The server processes jobs, so
the buffer keeps going down.
And the state of the chain would
be the number of jobs
that you have inside
your buffer.
Or you could be thinking about
active phone calls out of a
certain city.
Each time that the phone call
is placed, the number of
active phone calls
goes up by 1.
Each time that the phone call
stops happening, is
terminated, then the count
goes down by 1.
So it's for processes of this
kind that a model with this
structure is going to show up.
And they do show up in
many, many models.
Or you can think about the
number of people in a certain
population that have
a disease.
So 1 more person gets the
flu, the count goes up.
1 more person gets healed,
the count goes down.
And these probabilities in such
an epidemic model would
certainly depend on
the current state.
If lots of people already have
the flu, the probability that
another person catches it
would be pretty high.
Whereas, if no one has the flu,
then the probability that
you get a transition where
someone catches the flu, that
probability would
be pretty small.
So the transition rates, the
incidence of new people who
have the disease definitely
depends on how many people
already have the disease.
And that motivates cases where
those P's, the upward
transition probabilities,
depend on the
state of the chain.
So how do we study this chain?
You can sit down and write the
system of n linear equations
in the pi's.
And this way, find the
steady-state probabilities of
this chain.
But this is a little harder.
It's more work than one
actually needs to do.
There's a very clever shortcut
that applies
to birth/death processes.
And it's based on the frequency
interpretation that
we discussed a little
while ago.
Let's put a line somewhere in
the middle of this chain, and
focus on the relation between
this part and that part in
more detail.
So think of the chain continuing
in this direction,
that direction.
But let's just focus on 2
adjacent states, and look at
this particular cut.
What is the chain going to do?
Let's say it starts here.
It's going to move around.
At some point, it makes a
transition to the other side.
And that's a transition
from i to i+1.
It stays on the other
side for some time.
It gets here, and eventually,
it's going to make a
transition to this side.
Then it keeps moving
and so on.
Now, there's a certain balance
that must be obeyed here.
The number of upward transitions
through this line
cannot be very different from
the number of downward
transitions.
Because we cross this
way, then next time,
we'll cross that way.
Then next time, we'll
cross this way.
We'll cross that way.
So the frequency with which
transitions of this kind occur
has to be the same as the
long-term frequency that
transitions of that
kind occur.
You cannot go up 100 times and
go down only 50 times.
If you have gone up 100 times,
it means that you have gone
down 99, or 100, or 101,
but nothing much more
different than that.
So the frequency with
which transitions of
this kind get observed.
That is, out of a large number
of transitions, what fraction
of transitions are
of these kind?
That fraction has to be the
same as the fraction of
transitions that happened
to be of that kind.
What are these fractions?
We discussed that before.
The fraction of times at which
transitions of this kind are
observed is the fraction of time
that we happen to be at
that state.
And out of the times that we
are in that state, the
fraction of transitions that
happen to be upward
transitions.
So this is the frequency with
which transitions of this kind
are observed.
And with the same argument,
this is the frequency with
which transitions of that
kind are observed.
Since these two frequencies
are the same, these two
numbers must be the same, and
we get an equation that
relates the Pi to P_(i+1).
This has a nice form because
it gives us a recursion.
If we knew pi(i), we could then
immediately calculate pi(i+1).
So it's a system of equations
that's very
easy to solve almost.
But how do we get started?
If I knew pi(0), I could find
by pi(1) and then use this
recursion to find pi(2),
pi(3), and so on.
But we don't know pi(0).
It's one more unknown.
It's an unknown, and we need
to actually use the extra
normalization condition that
the sum of the pi's is 1.
And after we use that
normalization condition, then
we can find all of the pi's.
So you basically fix pi(0) as a
symbol, solve this equation
symbolically, and
everything gets
expressed in terms of pi(0).
And then use that normalization
condition to
find pi(0), and you're done.
Let's illustrate the details
of this procedure on a
particular special case.
So in our special case, we're
going to simplify things now
by assuming that all those
upward P's are the same, and
all of those downward
Q's are the same.
So at each point in time, if
you're sitting somewhere in
the middle, you have probability
P of moving up and
probability Q of moving down.
This rho, the ratio of P/Q is
frequency of going up versus
frequency of going down.
If it's a service system, you
can think of it as a measure
of how loaded the system is.
If P is equal to Q, it's means
that if you're at this state,
you're equally likely to move
left or right, so the system
is kind of balanced.
The state doesn't have a
tendency to move in this
direction or in that
direction.
If rho is bigger than 1 so that
P is bigger than Q, it
means that whenever I'm at some
state in the middle, I'm
more likely to move right rather
than move left, which
means that my state, of course
it's random, but it has a
tendency to move in
that direction.
And if you think of this as a
number of customers in queue,
it means your system has the
tendency to become loaded and
to build up a queue.
So rho being bigger than 1
corresponds to a heavy load,
where queues build up.
Rho less than 1 corresponds to
the system where queues have
the tendency to drain down.
Now, let's write down
the equations.
We have this recursion P_(i+1)
is Pi times Pi over Qi.
In our case here, the P's and
the Q's do not depend on the
particular index, so we
get this relation.
And this P over Q is just
the load factor rho.
Once you look at this equation,
clearly you realize
that by pi(1) is rho
times pi(0).
pi(2) is going to be --
So we'll do it in detail.
So pi(1) is pi(0) times rho.
pi(2) is pi(1) times rho,
which is pi(0) times
rho-squared.
And then you continue doing
this calculation.
And you find that you can
express every pi(i) in terms
of pi(0) and you get this
factor of rho^i.
And then you use the last
equation that we have -- that
the sum of the probabilities
has to be equal to 1.
And that equation is going to
tell us that the sum over all
i's from 0 to m of pi(0) rho
to the i is equal to 1.
And therefore, pi(0) is 1 over
(the sum over the rho to the i
for i going from 0 to m).
So now we found pi(0), and by
plugging in this expression,
we have the steady-state
probabilities of all of the
different states.
Let's look at some special
cases of this.
Suppose that rho
is equal to 1.
If rho is equal to 1, then
pi(i) is equal to pi(0).
It means that all
the steady-state
probabilities are equal.
It's means that every
state is equally
likely in the long run.
So this is an example.
It's called a symmetric
random walk.
It's a very popular model for
modeling people who are drunk.
So you start at a state
at any point in time.
Either you stay in place, or you
have an equal probability
of going left or going right.
There's no bias in
either direction.
You might think that in such a
process, you will tend to kind
of get stuck near one end
or the other end.
Well, it's not really clear
what to expect.
It turns out that in such a
model, in the long run, the
drunk person is equally
likely to be at any
one of those states.
The steady-state probability is
the same for all i's if rho
is equal to 1.
And so if you show up at a
random time, and you ask where
is my state, you will be told
it's equally likely to be at
any one of those places.
So let's make that note.
If rho equal to 1, implies
that all the
pi(i)'s are 1/(M+1) --
M+1 because that's how many
states we have in our model.
Now, let's look at
a different case.
Suppose that M is
a huge number.
So essentially, our supermarket
has a very large
space, a lot of space to
store their customers.
But suppose that the system
is on the stable side.
P is less than Q, which means
that there's a tendency for
customers to be served faster
than they arrive.
The drift in this chain, it
tends to be in that direction.
So when rho is less than 1,
which is this case, and when M
is going to infinity, this
infinite sum is the sum of a
geometric series.
And you recognize it
(hopefully) --
this series is going
to 1/(1-rho).
And because it's in the
denominator, pi(0) ends up
being 1-rho.
So by taking the limit as M
goes to infinity, in this
case, and when rho is less than
1 so that this series is
convergent, we get
this formula.
So we get the closed-form
formula for the pi(i)'s.
In particular, pi(i) is (1-
rho)(rho to the i).
to
So these pi(i)'s are essentially
a probability
distribution.
They tell us if we show up at
time 1 billion and we ask,
where is my state?
You will be told that
the state is 0.
Your system is empty with
probability 1-rho, minus or
there's one customer in the
system, and that happens with
probability (rho
- 1) times rho.
And it keeps going
down this way.
And it's pretty much a geometric
distribution except
that it has shifted so that it
starts at 0 whereas the usual
geometric distribution
starts at 1.
So this is a mini introduction
into queuing theory.
This is the first and simplest
model that one encounters when
you start studying
queuing theory.
This is clearly a model of a
queueing phenomenon such as
the supermarket counter with
the P's corresponding to
arrivals, the Q's corresponding
to departures.
And this particular queuing
system when M is very, very
large and rho is less than 1,
has a very simple and nice
solution in closed form.
And that's why it's
very much liked.
And let me just take
two seconds to
draw one last picture.
So this is the probability
of the different i's.
It gives you a PMF.
This PMF has an expected
value.
And the expectation, the
expected number of customers
in the system, is given
by this formula.
And this formula, which is
interesting to anyone who
tries to analyze a system
of this kind,
tells you the following.
That as long as a rho is less
than 1, then the expected
number of customers in
the system is finite.
But if rho becomes very
close to 1 --
So if your load factor is
something like .99, you expect
to have a large number of
customers in the system at any
given time.
OK.
All right.
Have a good weekend.
We'll continue next time.